Central we've got a 12f it's a darken
colored looks like uh Mercedes I 95
Northbound approaching the US One Stakes
are authorized for or units as well no
Pursuit everyone the
Channel all right he's weaving in out of
traffic here he's probably less than a
quarter mile out from us
one getting back on 95 90 Central notifi
flag
County car two to 90 you guys get them
with six
now he turned around right before me car
I'm with them it's uh 12f for now we're
not going to pursue let the helicopter
follow it we'll see if we can stick
it all right we're over 100 these
overtaken Vehicles we're still
Northbound we're about a mile out from
Old
Dixie
all right he's getting off at Old Dixie
getting off Old Dixie
95 all right he signal forward into the
grass rear bumper ripped off he's
driving through the grass he's going to
be eastbound on Old
Dixie East be set up sticks
US1 and the county
line
yeah Walter borom in rear bumper Hanging
On by a thread he's dragging his rear
bumper coming out some traffic a little
signal foring into Vehicles he's
continuing East on Walter Boardman past
High
Bridge all right we're at John Anderson
now stand
by
all right he's going to be eastbound on
Moody just lost the rear bumper still
westbound on Moody all right he's
slowing down he sees the units ahead of
him it's kind of stationary stand
by yep he stopped westbound all right
driver's getting out hands up it's like
he's uh giving up black male black
hoodie black beanie black
pants on
100 yep he's on 100 just uh east of
uh behind you behind you behind you
behind you stop
everybody all right unit see behind you
guys are passing turn back
around he's laid out prone in the
roadway
here all
right on the
west right in front of that
SUV
[Music]
I got a br arm I got a r in my arm kill
somebody pal I thought had War man
that's okay you got something for you
now for who for you for
what I
ain't
roll get up on one knee look I got a
broken H look at my I'm not looking at
your head get up on one
knee my arm I got to r on my arm then
help
yourself
I2 secure
147 have a seat say have a seat sit in
the
car going on yeah you're under arrest
for what told youing and
looing why in the car sit down Okay then
if you got a war I'm asking you do I
have a
CP man help me put my pants we don't
know who you are how do we know if you
got a one man I'm asking you do I have a
one I fled because I thought I had a
child support one what the that doesn't
give you an excuse to run yes it do I I
thought I had a war get inside car I'm
an idiot yeah it gives me an excuse to
run if I got good
job
[Music]
eventually one of the officers catches
up with Mitchell who almost hits a squad
car head
on want on with
[Music]
me
205 get
205 Lan
16 no
[Music]
TR separate dash camera video shows
these same moments from a third
angle 205 number one L speed of
75 number
[Music]
tra
102 number
traffic south 205 sou 205 try to
get5
spe
[Music]
as the chase picks up dash camera video
captures Mitchell brush up against the
road's median after that he loses
control spins out and crashes into a
dump truck the entire crash is caught on
camera
AC next multiple officers arrive on the
scene ride Park
[Music]
ride
6 vitim at Walmart she she has cut to
her leg at minimal and we need more
officers at least one more officer at
Walmart
we're coming back to Rockdale going to
be on access road headed back towards
Rock get this
GS up
there T4 we coming back TOS on our Drive
[Applause]
the gas station on
our
and North Carina tag Frank John Tom 821
fjt 821 blue
hondro
101 if start clearing
intersections
[Music]
aole
the
here
333 all overway we're
back to the gas
station
going
FL head back to BL
off he made a left on flat show we
passing a
Avendale next
aut
just pass
striction coming back off to IR Drive
intersection hit my
vehicle
41 41
41 hours and
[Music]
Flash
continue in
field
[Music]
f
and ch
dve
behind
this way
[Music]
15 one can 27 on that
Ma just
s t hyund it looks like they just took a
here off not going be injuring
continuing Westbound at Rocky River
speeds are
35 yeah just side swiped another man
here continuing westbound maybe here
we're at the intersection of Rocky River
Park Road Sid Swip a third
[Music]
vehicle still West Bound Brook
Park 66o appears that she was
intentionally trying to push in other
cars
we still left found on Park Road we're
coming up M the bridge here coming into
fairv park if you can give them a call
and let them
know coming up to Gren and looks like
we're going to go pass Gren continuing
West 40
Lo there's debris on the roadway curve
lane two tires we're getting on 480 East
and it looks like speeds are about 15
right now might be coming to a stop here
on
the cars having trouble holding it
together driving off the road here on
the on ramp 480 east 480 Eastbound
across all the lanes to the pass Lane
speeds are only about
right now no tires on the left side of
the
car make a wall stay wide behind
me all right everybody move
what 4 East right now speeds are about
53 whoever's directly behind this car be
careful there's going to be Shel coming
off there give me some
room 66 is directly behind it keep the
wall don't let any cars pass
you com up to the 71 split they're
thinking taking it here they're weaving
back and forth between
lanes she's now going the wrong
direction on 40 eastbound we do have
traffic behind a stop though looks like
we're coming to a stop
here yeah we got to get this car stopped
we got to head on blocking
in
get out the vehicle get out get out of
the vehicle get out get out get the
out we're good fucking
car go
[Music]
[Applause]
here
coming up
to1
I
can't F keep also
Fai he's uh kind of flat or something
sure what he's doing but going be
Northbound D get back
there we just
31 stay
back 39
got the 13
nor we know we know hold on we got this
he's in the road we
know get a hand gun here hold
on watch he don't come back on us here I
see him is he is he walking or what's he
doing yeah he's
walking you got
it yeah there he's right
there oh he's way down there now he's
throwing his hands
up we're not approaching him on
foot get get down there you two get down
there start setting up a perimeter on
him we'll try to keep him
contained clear what Cook's clear all
right Madina comeer is number three l
Long Beach
boulard Long Beach
boulard traffic still late for number
four lane now coming up to the uh 7
freway number four lane Northbound 405
approaching 7
freway
all right we're all the way over to the
right stand
by2 we're
pro
41 106 getting on the uh
South Comm South Bound
[Music]
710 we have a pit roll over roll
over
[Music]
turn to our location as well as stage
fire andic male shaved head possibly
Hispanic blue shorts black
sweatshirt have a male
with
W with him he stopped and in the parking
lot your call has he's taking off again
he's a white male tattoos on his
[Music]
face
sh don't kill
me
has you drive we'll call
it
H jump now H
[Music]
jump incident
assigned they got hold
a just remains in
33 your call has been
updated your call has been updated
[Music]
hands up come back to me walk back come
to walk back come back to
me want to walk on him
no 40 40 40 okay hey watch his
hands hey get your
hands y yes it's by the front tire let's
let's smash him smash
go get his hand get his hands got hand
got one
hand
clear you're clear go
clear
that don't
that
[Music]
time
oh
you get up there so you can
see
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
you
body camera video shows these same
moments from another
[Applause]
perspective after the crash little JN
hops out of the stolen vehicle and runs
off dash camera video shows officers
chase after
him
this video shows the moments from the
crash all the way to the chase when
little John is tackled to the
ground all right cash cash you all right
you all right come here budy come here
pocket come here
cash pocket come here pocking cash
pocking pocking cash pocking pocking
stop get by
a stop moving I got you stop
resisting fuck resist body camera video
from another officer shows these same
moments from another
angle St Got Hand what's in the other
one
hold it
there you're going to get T little JN is
tased multiple times but still refuses
to cooperate with
police let it
go pull your pull your hand
go let it go let your hand go
I no off
me it's a gun
I know it is you want to get fucking
shot over this let it
go go
go let me shoot me let's shoot me
first shoot me pass
Bo shoot me you're going to get bit
you're going to get bit you're going to
get tased until you put that arm out oh
no do you want to get
bit you want to get
bit
okay let me go let me me go real
quick God n
Go n please no no please let your hand
out and now let your neck go I think you
hold my neck let my neck go don't need
your neck to let your hand out now do it
now okay okay okay get your head out now
get it out but when things calm down
little John asks officers to pull down
his mask but they refuse right you're
good shut up
no just get your breath you're
good you're ready we'll get them up
my down please what put my mask down
please what do you want my mask down P
my mask down I'm not pulling your mask
down I don't care about your mask I
really have as long oh yeah okay that's
great you're talking and breathing
perfectly fine right
now are you ready yeah we're going to
stand you up stand up if you try to
fight me I'm going to put you on the
ground again you understand me yeah keep
stand
up don't go that way get up get
up
eventually little Jung cooperates and
officers detain him ready to
[Music]
roll out of your
mind keep him
there good boy good boy good boy good
boy good
boy after he's in cuffs Little John
continues to complain about problems
breathing but officers push
back
[Applause]
uhhuh emance
please
why I can't either and I'm
good
right got
your
the for what
talking you can breathe sure shit
weren't having those complaints when you
riding around like in your
face they'll be here in a minute
okay put two put one I want one set of
cuffs on him you try to move I'm going
to drop a knee on you do you understand
me it's not going to be pretty I'm going
to drop all my weight on you you're not
going to like it okay he's fucking all
he's already looking
to swoop them under and it ain't
happening I can't breathe stop moving
your hands I can't breathe not a if
you're talking you're
breathing
ief I can't breathe you're talking still
so you know how I know you're breathing
cuz you're still talking just PE on my
pleas let my leg go oh that sucks should
have went to the bathroom before your
little
Escapade Little John maintains he needs
to go to the hospital so EMS is called
to the
scene just so you know this isn't
getting you out of jail we're going to
go with you to the hospital and then
we're going to take you to jail so
you're ain't going to fly with me you're
still going all right just so you know
okay take you take care of yourself all
right as he's being loaded into the
ambulance Little John pulls his shirt
over his face but officers pull it right
off yeah oh hey don't do that you said
you can't breathe remember you don't
want to put your shirt over your
face can you stop
moving yeah that's going to help that's
not going to help your breathing there
oh you don't want to be on the news
that's not going to help if you can't
breathe I don't want your shirt over
your face you my suffocate yourself
don't want to do that just looking out
for your